[Music]
hello, how are you, Sal y Jaramillo greets you
with your briefing today, Monday,
August 16. Today there will be a federal announcement
about the lack of water from
the Colorado River. The federal
water recovery agency will offer a
conference this afternoon to discuss the
conditions.  of drought and the future of the
lake look at this announcement however it
will not have much impact here in the
valley the most affected will be the
farmers of arizona
this week workers prepare
to clean the rubble left by the
collapse of the structure in the pretty
supermarket located near the  jazz verin
and string friday morning
front of building
collapsed reported four people injured
and employees had to evacuate
starting today all
unvaccinated state employees will
be required to get a weekly kobe screening on
employees should show
the results to the
human resources department or their s
direct supervisor to those in
government places with 70% vaccination
do not need to follow these rules
and if you still do not know where to get the
vaccine there will be two vaccination clinics
for this week one is at now cafe on
the second floor of las vegas it was said on
Wednesday from eight thirty to one in the
afternoon another of the clinics will be at the
ranch high school on Saturday from nine
in the morning to two in the afternoon for a
complete view you can enter our
page disney.com the section in Spanish
and now we will  According to the weather forecast
today we will have temperatures
reaching 108 degrees with a sunny sky
however for tomorrow we will have a slight
chance of drizzle with a maximum of
103 degrees it will continue in triple digits for
the rest of the week nice day
greets you I went out Jaramillo and this was your
brief informative edition in Spanish
[Music]